now the right argument the republican
argument right now seems to be well
let's do a
six to seven hundred billion dollar
package let's do that let's let's do the
infrastructure
but uh republicans are obviously heavily
opposed to
uh green and uh climate initiatives
energy efficiency standards you know
donald trump one of the big things he
did was
remove energy efficiency requirements or
at least some of them
for vehicles to say hey well if we lower
prices people can afford a new car and
that'll increase average fuel efficiency
what's your stand on that
well listen for whatever reason
republicans seem
extremely intimidated by large packages
they have a tendency for small sometimes
very weak packages with terrible
performance if you understand what i'm
saying
reading between the lines here right
yeah so um i i think that
the games around fine-tuning package
size
are less interesting to me than
fundamentally
what one's philosophical approach to the
role of government should be
because really it's not that if the
package is a little tinier
or it's a little flimsier republicans
all of a sudden
love it it's they don't believe
fundamentally
that the government should be even
involved in this
many of them because they are such
extreme small government conservatives
so it's not even
you know package size they they try to
flaunt
tiny packages i don't know what they're
bragging about quite frankly
but i i i don't even think they're
talking in good faith quite frankly
gotcha yeah got it so it's it's really
more of just a contrasting argument like
there's there's not a small package to
be had that would
function as well as this it's just we
don't want you know two two let's how
about 600
that's exactly right the small package
is not going to work that well i think
you understand what i'm saying
nobody likes small packages right we
gotta have big packages in america